7 8 l'actu sur TVfil 78 il est 18h si
vous nous rejoignez en direct nous
faisons comme chaque soir de la semaine
le tour de l'actualité locale on débute
par la situation de crise qui perdure à
l'université de Versailles Saint-Quentin
en fin de semaine dernière le conseil
d'administration s'est réunit une
nouvelle fois pour voter le budget 2014
en déficit de plus de 5 millions une
procédure que l'État ne peut accepter
c'est donc le rectorat qui reprend la
main à lui maintenant de trouver des
solutions pour faire des économies
Catherine zulator jour le montant du
déficit de fonctionnement affiché par
l'université de Versailles Saint-Quentin
nouveau conseil d'administration
vendredi dernier pour valider le budget
2014 un budget présenté en déséquilibre
et donc encore refusé par le rectorat
représentant de l'État une ultime date
est fixée le 1er mars l'université aura
son budget à ce moment-là mais de quoi
sera-t-il composé de moyens
supplémentaires octroyés par le
ministère ou alors faudra-t-il faire des
coupes sombres les syndicats se
distinguaient déclarent que la stratégie
du ministère effectivement jouer la
montre pour ne pas doter l'université
qui ne peut pas fonctionner sans cette
dotation de toute façon et il y a une
attente qui je pense repose aussi sur
des espoirs que l'université fassent le
maximum aille le plus loin possible
effectivement dans les économies mais du
coup ce qui met clairement très
gravement en danger l'université de
Versailles Saint-Quentin aujourd'hui si
le ministère n'investit pas davantage de
moyens dans les universités en
particulier dans l'ubsq très sincèrement
et voilà des conséquences en termes de
pédagogie en termes de recherche en
termes d'encadrement et de nombre de
personnes dans les amphis des
conséquences qui sont catastrophiques
sur la réussite des étudiants à l'USQ
selon lunf 30% des masters pourraient
être menacés de fermeture en cas de
restriction budgétaire sévère le
syndicat veut rester mobilisé et appelé
pourquoi pas manifester après les
vacances de février dans un communiqué
de presse la présidence précise que le
ministère souhaite aider l'université
sous forme d'une subvention
exceptionnelle remboursable
en contrepartie d'économie
supplémentaire à réaliser par l'UVSQ
mais sans en préciser le montant
plusieurs réunions de concertation sont
prévues dans les jours qui viennent
l'ensemble du budget sera connu le 1er
mars
la mobilité 2.0 comprenait les
transports intelligents les transports
de demain une conférence nationale sur
ce sujet se déroulait la semaine
dernière à Versailles en présence du
ministre Frédéric Cuvillier nous en
avons d'ailleurs parlé sur cette antenne
ce soir je reçois Jérôme Perrin bonsoir
La directeur général de l'Institut vdcom
vdcom pour véhicules des carbonées
communiquant et sa mobilité basé donc
dans les Yvelines depuis 2012 est-ce que
vous pouvez nous en dire un petit peu
plus sur cette institut sur son travail
au quotidien alors l'Institut vecom
d'abord c'est un c'est un objet nouveau
dans le paysage des instituts de
recherche puisque ça fait partie de ces
instituts du plan d'investissement
d'avenir nous lui par l'État qui sont
dans la fête des instituts de la
transition énergétique donc là pour le
coup appliqué au véhicule et à la
mobilité alors c'est ainsi
préexistait sous forme d'une fondation
fondation adossée à l'université verset
501 puisque les fondations partenariales
de l'UVSQ et puis qui a commencé à
travailler déjà depuis 2012 on a déjà
embauché à Salon de thésard de post-dogs
chercheurs etc et moi-même j'ai été mise
à disposition par Renault pour diriger
cette institut alors institut de
recherche partenariale public privé qui
suppose des contributions venant
de recherche académique comme lui VSQ
mais aussi lifestar
l'INRIA Rocquencourt
ParisTech et un salon d’autres ESTACA
qui basait à Montigny maintenant qui va
être basé à Montigny et puis et d'autres
écoles et puis les grands de la filière
automobile Renault PSA Valeo mais aussi
continental à Rambouillet et puis un
salon d'autres qui sont pas de la
filière automobile au sens strict mais
qui concerne la mobilité alors ça va
depuis le les espaces des
infrastructures routières on a Koffi
route et puis on a aussi à REP qui sont
une fille assez snif qui s'occupe de
d'aménagement de gare et de territoire
on a aussi les espaces numériques avec
Atos
les espaces énergétiques avec EDF voilà
donc on a un certain nombre de
représentants d'un certain nombre de
métiers et de filières industrielle qui
sont mis ensemble avec 50
disons qu'on a surtout un cœur de
partenaire qui sont très fortement
engagés qui ont le même droit les mêmes
devoirs que l'UVSQ que PSA Valeo c'est
une vingtaine on a un deuxième cercle de
partenaire qui sont un peu moins
impliqués qui n'ont pas accès à la
gouvernance mais qui participent au
projet et puis on a quelques autres qui
sont des donateurs donc en gros c'est 45
c'est d'ailleurs pas limité dans le
temps c'est que d'autres candidats sont
bienvenus s'il remplissent un centre de
conditions et d'engagement de ressources
puisque outre l'argent de l'État il y
aura des abondements de des partenaires
industriels qui mettront de l'argent et
des personnes qui seront mises à
disposition il y aura aussi les
établissements académiques qui vont
faire de même et puis
on a aussi donc l'abondement du Conseil
Général des Yvelines qui va s'est engagé
à apporter 20 millions en complément des
prêts de 55 millions de l'État j'aurais
juste ouvrir une parenthèse concernant
l'université de Versailles 50 ans en
Yvelines on en parlait au début de ce
journal et depuis plusieurs mois
maintenant de ses difficultés
financières de cet université est-ce que
ça vous inquiète pour ne serait-ce que
le projet vdcom déjà alors il s'agit
pour le l'université surtout de mettre à
disposition des gens d'encadrer des
tests donc nous on est là aussi pour
donc valider un centre de sujets donc
l'apport que je pense que ça ne nous a
pas inquiété outre mesure c'est que
l'université continue à jouer son rôle
dans la biodiversité de faire des
économies elle pourrait faire des
économies sur ce type de projet par
exemple
et donc pour l'instant je ne préjuge pas
de l'avenir je pense que l'engagement en
tout cas de tous les partenaires qui
tels que ça s'est manifesté lors du 11
février était très fort nous avons déjà
des projets bien lancés nous avons pour
montrer aussi aussi la force frappe de
s'insister nous avons réussi en moins
d'un an alors que nous n'existions même
pas à avoir deux projets européens dans
et nous inscrire tout de suite dans
d'autres projets européens qui sont trop
de constitution pourquoi parce qu'on y
va j'allais dire en meute donc en
mettant ensemble tout sur un domaine
donné qui suit de notre la mobilité à
Salon de partenaires privés publics qui
vont ensemble et qui vont à la chasse
aux projets européens alors c'est pas
notre seule mission bien entendu il y a
les projets qui ont été validés par les
partenaires qui s'agit de monter mais
encore une fois on a une bande dans une
dynamique très forte et je pense que
l'université de versa 50 ans et dans
cette dynamique va continuer en tout cas
à travailler au sein de VD comme alors
il y a eu cette visite deux ministres
cette visite de ministre autour d'une
mobilité 2.0 ça signifie quoi que le
véhicule de demain c'est déjà pour
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment pour demain
et pas dans un futur un peu éloigné ou
c'était juste un coup de communication
il y a une feuille de route derrière si
vous voulez que les les progrès d'abord
on parle de véhicule de mobilité
intelligent de système oblique
intelligent on parle de véhicules
autonomes on parle de véhicules
connectés sont trois choses qui sont
légèrement différentes et puis on parle
de véhicules électriques aussi donc tous
ces choses là sont des éléments d'un
système qui vise à dressé finalement les
nouvelles solutions de mobilité du point
de vue de l'usager nous nous partons de
celui du point de vue de l'usager qui
doit se déplacer d'un point à un point B
dans un minimum de temps et avec le
minimum d'impact énergétique et
environnemental c'est ça j'irai le point
de départ et puis pour cela des
véhicules des véhicules électriques des
véhicules autonomes est connecté
pourquoi parce que ils peuvent à la fois
être plus fluide dans le trafic et donc
diminuer leur impact énergétique
améliorer la conduite et la fusée du
trafic connectée parce qu'ils peuvent
avoir accès des services des services
qui peuvent déboucher sur la
multimodalité ou l'intermodalité
c'est-à-dire passer du véhicule à
éventuellement un autre mode de
transport ou bien pratiquer ce qu'on
appelle le covoiturage dynamique comment
ça marchera concrètement dans sa voiture
on a des informations sur des
disponibilités pour ensuite prendre en
vélo par exemple
donc ça c'est l'aspect connexion oui
c'est le véhicule connecté n'oublions
pas que chacun maintenant a des
smartphones donc c'est en gros comment
pratiquer la continuité du point de vue
de l'individu de son smartphone à sa
voiture et de sa voiture à d'autres
modes de transport donc c'est tout un
aspect qui va contribuer à développer de
nouveaux services aussi et alors une
chose très importante dans les décors
c'est l'inscription dans les territoires
donc nous avons dans les membres
fondateurs dans les membres disons
constitutif devaient décom de comité
d'agglomération Versailles Grand Parc et
51 Yvelines nous avons aussi
l'établissement public Paris Saclay qui
sont très impliqués je dirais dans
l'inscription dans les territoires de ce
de ces nouveaux projets alors par
exemple une des missions qu'on s'est
donnée c'est
en tenant compte si vous voulez des
demandes et des attentes des enquêtes de
mobilité des plans locaux de déplacement
comment à travers ça aussi
proposer des solutions intelligentes de
mobilité et qui puisse aussi faire place
à ces nouvelles technologies c'est à
dire comment combiner à la fois une
attente des territoires qui ont besoin
de répondre à des demandes des usagers
et en même temps de faire place à des
nouvelles technologies et donc cette
espèce d'alchimie on essaie de la faire
en réunissant autour de la table de
comité animation un établissement public
des opérateurs transports comme Transdev
qui font partie aussi de benecom j'avais
oublié des cités au début
des opérateurs
et des constructeurs de automobile qui
eux ont besoin de tester ces nouveaux
véhicules et faire évoluer sur le
territoire vous testez et vous part
travailler avec des partenaires
véritablement locaux on l'a compris on a
compris aussi qu'il y avait un enjeu
très important juste pour conclure
aujourd'hui avec ce type de structure ça
peut permettre à la France d'être à la
pointe en matière automobile alors oui
je pense que doré un peu son blason on
s'étend difficile oui en tout cas les
toutes les compétences sont là on voit
bien la richesse des compétences
n'oublions pas aussi ainsi que nous
avons vénéré dans dans vdcom pas
seulement des techniciens de
l'automobile pas seulement des
électroniciens ou des gens des moteurs
mais aussi des sociologues des ergonomes
des psychologues donc vraiment une date
proche très transversale et très
complète de ce qu'on appelle
l'écosystème de la mobilité intelligente
merci Jean-Pierre d'être venu sur ce
plateau directeur général donc de cet
institut vdcom vous l'avez compris nous
parlons de l'avenir de la voiture la
mobilité 2.0 on a encore bien sûr
l'occasion d'en reparler merci à vous
merci l'actualité de ce 17 février est
également politique le Front national
officiellement déposé en préfecture
c'est un premier liste finalisée dans le
département municipal c'est celle de
Philippe Chevrières Rambouillet
rappelons qu'en 2008 la formation de
Marine Le Pen avait présenté aucun
candidat le Front national annonce cette
année avoir désigné dans les Yvelines 23
têtes de liste 8 à 9 serait sur le point
de dévoiler l'ensemble de leurs
colistier on reste dans la politique
avec cette dernière séance de Robert CAD
lbert le président PS de l'agglomération
de 50 ans en Yvelines vous le savez ne
sera pas candidat un nouveau mandat il
était en poste depuis 16 ans Catherine
zulator
mais même après pour à ma place aider
toujours à cette réussite
Robert kadalbert a présidé sa dernière
séance du conseil communautaire c'était
jeudi dernier il a choisi de ne pas être
présent sur une liste aux municipales en
mars prochain Robert Cadalbert 69 ans et
président de l'agglomération depuis 16
ans il aura présidé sans conseil et a
posé 500000 fois ça signature un peu
d'émotion c'est une page qui se tourne
et donc les pages qu'on les tourne
surtout quand ils sont si belles que
celle-là on les tourne avec beaucoup de
nostalgie la première réussite c'est
bien sûr la réussite économique de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et pas pour la
création de richesse mais effectivement
pour l'emploi pour le partage de cette
richesse au travers de l'emploi alors il
y a encore beaucoup à faire
c'est vrai que s'il y a pas cette
réussite économique il n'y a pas de
partage aujourd'hui la réussite
économique est à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines alors ce que
je regrette c'est ce que je dis c'est
qu'effectivement la réussite économique
de 50 ans de mines c'est pas encore le
plein emploi à Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
et donc particulièrement l'emploi des
jeunes et pour savoir quelle image va
laisser Robert Cadalbert nous sommes
allés poser la question aux plus anciens
conseillers communautaire le mot qui
ressort consensus une recherche du
consensus je pense
principalement enfin de voilà je pense
que ça a été une des caractéristiques de
son mandat on a connu donc la présidence
de Robert cavalbert ou là on a eu un
partage des responsabilités je crois que
c'est comme ça que la communauté d'agglo
doit travailler un homme de dialogue
qui sert l'intérêt général puisque
lorsqu'il y a des projets que ça soit
sur Montigny trappes la verrière ou une
Guyancourt et bien il travaille en
collaboration étroite avec les maires je
dis souvent c'est ma formation de base
de capitaine de l'équipe de rugby
championne de France en 1963 voilà et
effectivement toute ma vie le rugby m'a
apporté cette capacité à dynamiser une
équipe il y a deux façons de faire du
management soit en imposant des choix
soit en montrant l'exemple et puis
enfonçant et puis en amenant les gens
dans cette dynamique Robert Cadalbert
quittera le conseil communautaire à
l'issue des élections municipales mais
il continuera à s'imp liquer dans la
ville locale à travers l'organisation de
la Ryder Cup en 2018 et au-delà de la
candidature de la France aux Jeux
olympiques en 2024
et poursuivre l'actualité des
municipales de la campagne rendez-vous
chaque mardi à 18h30 pour municipale
2014 l'émission n'oubliez pas également
les débats organisés par entre les
différents candidats sur notre antenne
par TVfil donc c'est le mardi et le
jeudi à 20h un mot de sport pour
terminer du handball cinquième journée
de la phase finale du championnat de
France des moins et de 18 ans plaisir
recevait le leader Créteil et à Pierre
de Coubertin les plaisirs roi en noir
entame très bien la rencontre mais le
demi finaliste de la saison passée qui
prend peu à peu l'ascendant pour mener
16 à 12 à la pause au retour des
vestiaires la logique est respectée la
victoire de Créteil 35 à 27 malgré cette
défaite plaisir conserve ça troisième
place pour l'essentiel du sport
rendez-vous comme chaque lundi soir à
18h30 avec Anthony rechesson et 7 8
sport l'actu revient demain en direct à
18h excellente soirée sur notre antenne